the defense has rested in the trial of a
hillary clinton campaign lawyer accused
of lying to the fbi about the
trump-russia probe michael sussman chose
not to testify in his own defense
correspondent david spunt is outside the
federal courthouse here in washington as
he's been every night to tell us where
things stand tonight good evening david
brett two major developments in court
today the first we know that closing
arguments will kick out tomorrow the
second one is the fact that michael
sussman despite what some people thought
he may he ended up not testifying but it
was the first time brett that we heard
from michael sussman directly in court
as he stood before the judge christopher
cooper and confirmed to the judge that
he would not testify
to defend himself on the stand sussman
is charged with lying to the fbi
specifically then fbi general counsel
james baker when he came to baker in
september 2016 and said he had
information linking the trump
organization to a russian bank with
kremlin ties via a computer server john
durham the special counsel says the
actual lie is when sussman told baker he
was delivering the information on his
own not on behalf of any clients durham
argues that sussman went on behalf of
the clinton campaign and says that
billing evidence he showed jurors proves
it sussman's team says that he did
nothing wrong and has had a long working
relationship with the fbi and would
never lie to the bureau
judge cooper today brett read
instructions to jurors told them to
weigh several questions chiefly was
michael sussman's statement false
fictitious and material to the
investigation also did michael sussman
act knowingly or willfully with the
intention to break the law the final
question was the statement made in the
executive branch of government in this
case the fbi if jurors believe the
government proved its case beyond a
reasonable doubt they are instructed to
find michael sussman guilty
after closing arguments tomorrow
deliberations will likely begin tuesday
after the long weekend and brett if i
may with some color from the courtroom
today i noticed and i've noticed this
every day special counsel john durham is
actively involved in this case he sits
at the table with his attorneys he takes
notes he passes notes even today he
crossed over to the aisle to make small
talk with michael sussman's defense team
as michael sussman just sat stoically a
few feet away brett all right we'll now
wait for the jury david thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else